Mike Vrabel is the head coach of my
Tennessee Titans they of course lost to
the Chiefs in the AFC Championship game
and had a great season coach good
morning how are you I'm doing great guys
how are you hope everybody staying safe
and being healthy what do you bench in
nowadays coach man it's all push-ups
that's it really I lift enough man I got
my Tyler's at BC he's offensive lineman
so he's these one doing lifting and and
I'm trying to stay in that that dad bond
flow do you ever miss hitting somebody
yeah I mean I think you missed the the
contact of a football I think that's why
I enjoy getting out there with the
players and in trying to teach and and
develop those guys on the field how do
you keep in touch with your players
right now we you know just using the
team work apps sending text messages and
really the way that we have the meetings
scheduled through through the zoom I can
walk it's like I'm walking out of my
office I walk in the o-line meeting at
10:00 I hang out there and see those
guys visit with that group that's
probably one of my favorite groups just
because of the types of personalities
that they have in there in the bond that
they have and then I'll go in and pop in
the DB meeting after that visit with
those guys and kind of work my way
around see the quarterbacks and
receivers at noon outside linebackers
after that and inside linebackers D line
goes at 11:30 so it's been pretty cool
we've been able to structure those
meetings in the player set the schedule
that they wanted to meet and the coaches
are available how about the workouts for
these players if they don't have a
facility to go to I think it's important
that everybody stays self-motivated
during this time it's not something that
we're trying to track we're trying to be
conscious of guys and wait there's two
types of players when you think about
our football team or anybody's team that
maybe they have to concentrate on not
being overweight at this time maybe a
bigger lineman
but then some of these players that have
to concentrate on on keeping their
weight up and so really I think they're
they're working and I think that the
guys are staying self-motivated they're
they're getting together they're
communicating with our strength coach
but we're not
during those workouts let's talk about
the the virtual draft the setup at the
at the house red house who scripted that
I don't think anybody was scripted I
think what happened was this is the kids
were excited like like everybody else
was and we got a full house you know Jen
and I here and in Tyler's 19 Jackson's
19 and he's been with us for a year and
a half and Carter is 18 and he's
graduating so it's like living and
obviously me it's like a frat house and
that's and I never was in a fraternity
at Ohio State but I can only imagine
that this is what it would look like and
so I think when they saw that kids were
on the screen they wanted to do
something fun they wanted to be a part
of it
next thing I know I look around for Abel
Jersey from a Pro Bowl there's a there's
a Frozone costume and again I these guys
they they I love them to death they
support me and they just you know they
were having fun with it you kind of
stole the draft there for a little bit
you know because I wasn't sure what was
going on I certainly wasn't quite sure
what was going on they're good kids and
you know they're trying to keep their
rooms clean and their cars and they
Belichick had his dog there I didn't
know I was doing some research here
Brady's first career start that was
against the cult and you were his
teammate you remember that yeah yeah you
guys shut down Peyton Manning Brady's
last star with the Patriots the wild
card game and you're the winning coach
there how weird was that did you have
any sense that that was the last time
Tom was going to play for the Patriots
you know I wasn't really focused on that
I was trying to focus on preparing our
team to go into a place in January that
you know not too many teams at one I
think they were 20 and 3 in the playoffs
at home but looking back on
now you know Tom and I have a unique
relationship having played with him and
been in his teammate being friends and
then obviously competing against them I
think it's a unique relationship you
know he's a great phenomenal career
there and obviously still wants to play
football
was he and play it all for the Titans
anybody that was available in free
agency is available for the Titans I
think that John and I talked about that
all the time is find a way to to improve
our team well said
did you recruit him thank you you don't
this isn't College football you know we
draft them and we and we pay them this
isn't college football but you have to
recruit and be on Twitter and all the
other stuff well I I think Brady
recruited the Buccaneers it sounds like
he was you know when I talked to Bruce
Arians it felt like Brady was saying hey
I want to come there I'm coming there
basically like a kid commits to going to
college it felt like that wouldn't
that's what he was doing with Tampa also
I wanted to ask you and you told this
story this a couple years ago that I
think you made the mistake of saying to
Tom in the huddle that you were you were
open and I come back in the huddle and I
was like I was wide open he goes Mikey
if you ever raise your hands and I'll
never thirty the boys like I'm like
Randy Randy always raises Randy Moss is
allowed to raise his head you weren't
allowed to and did you keep those
footballs what do you have ten touchdown
receptions well if you count the Super
Bowls so that that's something that that
obviously was really cool but the thing
that you saw on draft night like
kids would take those footballs from the
Super Bowl and we go back to Ohio and
they'd be outside I don't have any
football there's no jerseys there's
nothing up like I'm concentrating on
being the best coach I can I love our
players I miss on the death I'm not I'm
not concentrated on you know what my
career was that's not going to help us
oh no I just didn't know if you had
those footballs no I couldn't tell you
we've been through four or five houses
since then and it's usually if the rule
is if it stays in a box more than two
moves it gets thrown out Wow well how
would you do if Derrick Henry was coming
through the line I would go low who is
he remind you of with that style I don't
know I mean I played bigger backs you
know Jerome Bettis was a bigger back
Eddie George is probably a close
comparison just because of the length
that he was as a taller back Jerome was
much more compact he just very long and
he's fast in the open field he's just he
runs away from a lot of people and our
guys love blocking for him I love
coaching him
you know he's done a lot of great things
for us Jerome Bettis would tell me
stories he said that he would hear
defensive players grunt or groan after
they tackled him because it was just
like he knew he was inflicting pain on
you I mean he had to be my when I was
finishing up in Pittsburgh he had to be
275 and this is a running back look like
a free man yeah I can't imagine there
are guys who you know they get small
sometimes when those big guys come
through the line and then all of a
sudden you kind of fall down or you know
that somebody got an arm on you and you
can't get to the running back you know
it's trying to get those guys before
they get going because if they build up
a head of steam if they get through the
front of the line somebody's had a bad
day it's great to talk to your coach and
congrats on the success last year and
hopefully we we figured this out at some
point but thank you for joining us
I certainly appreciate you guys fall
tightens and stay safe out there guys
stay healthy that's my grayble